HE WAS PLEASED ARE THE RESULT OF
THAT GAME. AND GOT THE RIGHT
AND CONNOR COMES IN THE SHORT S
THE SAVE IS MADE ON THAT.
HAS ROOM TO HELLEBUCYK MAY HAVE
WHEELER, THERE IS A LOTOT
A LONG SHOT IN.
AN
PIONK TIE IT UP IN THE CORNER.
DO WITH WHAT HE'S GONE THROUGH
NUMBER ONE THEY GET THE FIRST
GOAL OF THE GAME
>> Dennis: DID I REALLY SE
WHEELER TRACKS IT DOWN FOR
CONNOR AND CIRASTNY TO THE FOER
THE NET AND IT'S PASSED UP THE
MIDDLE.
MAYBE MORE HIGH-SCORING GAMES
AND LOWRY
>> Kevin: I NEVER NOTICED A
FLASH.
THESE COACHES DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT A LITTLE BIT LONGER TO GET
THE DECISION. SENDS IT
IT.SIDE.UPUP
ADAM LOWRY WITH 90STASTNY, MAYO
HIM UP FOCHLT
MADE BY AND
GETS TO THE FRONT OF THE NET
SHIFTS, AS THE FOURTH THE
SKATES OF SCHMALTZ AND CLEARED.
ONE SHOT ON THAT POWERPLAY. FRI
SEE FROM TEAMS.
FOR CONNOR, FIRESS, OFF THE SHO
TIED. -- THE
FACT THAT IT WENT UP INTO THE
NETTING.
AND HERE'S THE SHOT EARLIERSCHM
>> Dennis:
BORDER, SCHEIFELE WITH THE BREAK